[Music]
[Applause]
it's fall and kids are back in school a
place where they should feel safe so
they can learn but what if the people
who are supposed to keep those kids safe
are actually putting them in danger I'll
explain in a segment called how did we
get here
last month in Tennessee a sheriff's
deputy pepper sprayed and arrested a
high school student now I know what
you're thinking dang what did that kid
do to get pepper sprayed well the answer
is he refused to participate in a game
of kickball which sounds reasonable to
me because kickball sucks that I've
never watched baseball and thought I
wish this sport had more soccer in it
a kid for not wanting to play kickball
is insane but when I heard that story I
couldn't help but wonder why was that
officer at the school in the first place
well that's what we're going to talk
about today because that sheriff's
deputy was something called an SRO and
that stands for a school resource
officer a school resource officer
actually sounds pretty great like the
person you go to when you need
construction paper or when Kevin eats
all the glue but
according to the Department of Justice
sros are sworn Law Enforcement Officers
responsible for safety and crime
prevention in schools in other words
they're actual cops who hang out at
schools in case some kid doesn't feel
like playing kickball but at least they
can't arrest children right wrong
because they're active officers sros can
arrest children and they do basically
sros are like those old school paper
Cutters they're supposed to be helpful
but in reality they are quite dangerous
can you believe we used to put one of
these in every third grade classroom
ain't nothing but a rusty little
guillotine
these sros are policing all kids equally
right wrong again according to an ACLU
study in California sros
disproportionately arrest Latina boys
and students with disabilities also
black students are three times more
likely to be referred to law enforcement
compared to White students that is one
of those statistics you wish you never
learned like that one about how the
average person swallows seven spiders in
their lifetime or the fact that white
people don't use washcloths
and black kids at schools with sros have
arrest rates that are over seven times
higher than in schools without even
worse USA Today discovered that police
in schools arrested an average of 130
children a year from ages five to nine
yeah five to nine you cannot arrest a
five-year-old a five-year-old shouldn't
even go to Monopoly jail go on ahead and
collect that two hundred dollars or roll
again and baby now I don't want to say
what people who arrest five-year-olds
deserve but I will say it involves this
now
the thing is even if the school's SRO
doesn't arrest you that doesn't mean
you're off the hook because officers
also give tickets for smaller
infractions and those Target minorities
too according to propublica in one
Illinois School District black and
Latino students together received about
65 percent of the tickets since 2018.
even though they were only 32 percent of
District enrollment come on the only
tickets that should go
disproportionately to people of color
are lizzo tickets
as a people we have been through a lot
and we deserve to watch her playing that
slave holders flute
[Applause]
the fines aren't small left unpaid fines
can go to debt collectors and land kids
in the court system before they're old
enough to have their first job it's also
worth noting that a lot of these tickets
are for relatively small things like
possession of e-cigarettes or truancy
now I'm not condoning smoking and
skipping school I'm just saying if
School wasn't a place where they gave
out tickets and arrested people maybe
kids would stop vaping and show up now
as I think we've established the
presence of sros in schools is bad but
at least they're only punishing kids for
things they've actually done right wrong
a third time didn't you see that coming
don't you know how this show goes you're
wrong
sometimes you don't even have to do
anything wrong to get in trouble with
sros you heard me right because right
now in at least one Florida county law
enforcement uses a system to predict
which kids are going to get in trouble
in the future and gets the police
involved in advance according to the
police manual the cops use personal
information to find at-risk youth who
are destined to a life of crime which is
horrifying no kid is destined to a life
of crime well except for this one
laughs
his toy is a weapon
it's an aggravated assault waiting to
heaven and the criteria the cops used to
decide if a student is at risk is
ridiculous according to the manual
getting a D grade or having a parent or
sibling go to prison could be enough to
put a child in the at-risk category well
the writer who wrote this piece would
like you to know that they have parents
who are both convicted felons and they
are doing just fine literally the only
thing they are at risk for is getting
sucked into a tiny house Hunter's
Marathon Now you listen to me Zachary
those houses are cute but they are not
practical now none of this is to say
that kids don't mess up they do that's
the whole point of being a kid but
that's why we need to teach them not
imprison them financially bankrupt them
or judge them based on their family's
problems so what do we do well one Los
Angeles District cut a third of the
school police budget and put that money
into something called the black student
achievement plan to support the mental
and academic well-being of black
students and yeah
I like it too but you want to know what
happened when they did that nothing the
kids felt safer and the school didn't
become a crime Den the police have tried
to convince us that if we reduce their
influence the world will look like a Mad
Max sequel but it won't well unless the
Mad Max sequel is called Mad Max you
stopped over policing us and things got
better
oh and remember that SRO at the
beginning who arrested a kid who didn't
want to play kickball well he left the
school and so far according to the
Sheriff's Office he has not been
replaced which is the right thing to do
because having police officers in
schools much like having these is just
too damn dangerous this has been how did
we get here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]